[Music]
hey tour date time west palm beach
improv
may 28th to the 30th and creek in the
cave in austin texas
june 6th you can go to my website for
tickets get your tickets now
big shout out today to helix sleep take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to the mattress that will give
you the best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at
slash helixsleep.com with hellofresh
you get pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered
right to your door skip trips to the
grocery store and count on hello fresh
to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit
go to hellofresh.com 12
griffin that's one two twelve griffin
and use
code 12 griffin for 12 free meals
including free shipping
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back
to your absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to ripping
with griffin got the singing
heavy once again we're back it's me i
got wiggy on the ones and twos
back there um today is
nba basketball i'm gonna review some
movies
wigs got some stuff for me but i really
appreciate you guys being here as always
make sure you subscribe
make sure you like do all that stuff
make sure you hit the uh
you know go to air griffin gaming do all
that stuff
and welcome back to
yeah i love a good hot effects mic
that's what that's all about but welcome
back to riffing with griffin everybody
we had we had a good week um
i think uh after the surprise of having
uh
somebody you know the new format the
first week people were like what is this
we you know get all the comments we've
got and then this week is more like okay
they're getting used to it and so we're
going to continue to build on uh
what we're doing here but you know again
i i appreciate all the feedback the
comments you got
you guys have sent a lot of lovely
feedback even the people that like say
don't like it or they're like you know
you should get somebody else she doesn't
have enough energy
or whatever that those people they still
write it out nicely
and i do uh appreciate that so thanks
for all the feedback of everything and
you know again once again welcome to
what griffin um first let me start with
this
my i remember if you remember last week
i was talking about american idol
and i was like that girl she got kicked
off
the girl i said was gonna for sure win
i forgot her name already grace not
grace um
the young white girl 16 with the black
hair
she she i i feel like she had everything
in place to win american idol and they
and they voted her off
and so they now who's left is willie
which i now i feel like willie's going
to win
is willy it's just girl grace and you
know
she sings so good and then then the
white boy with the guitar who i thought
he should not be there like in
comparison to you want to talk about
singing and being a star
he don't got the same talent level as
the the three the three people that's
left
he's great though don't get me wrong he
is great
okay well i forgot the guy's name too i
mean i forgot everybody's name i wasn't
i didn't even let him know i was going
to talk about this but i just remember
chase
yeah that guy's name is chase so chase
and i and now
i'm feeling like he might win
and if he wins this is the thing they
were talking about on american idol
before
they used to complain about oh it's
another white guy and a guitar
winning american idol and then these
like really great
singers they're not they they don't get
voted by the people so
it's just a weird thing i feel like oh
no is it gonna happen again so
now that little girl is gone who again
she's gonna be a star
like look out for her i wish i could
remember her name what's her name dude
the the um she was in the top five last
week
whatever her name is guys i'm sure in
the comments people are like put it's
like probably showing up in the comments
right now
you gotta be faster than this casey
bishop
casey bishop that's her name casey
bishop she is gonna be a star guarantee
it all right she like anyways they
kicked her off she didn't get enough
votes
and now we left with grace chase and uh
willie so now i'm pulling for willy
because at first i didn't think because
of the whole american idol package i
thought casey was gonna win she just got
the whole package she's a really great
singer
talented she's young she's beautiful
that's everything that goes into
american idol let's just be honest about
it
willie is the best singer you know what
i mean there she is right there
if you're looking on youtube but you
know willie's the best
singer um but you know he's
he he's not necessarily the
quintessential
prototype what you want american idol to
look like i mean
it's still an image-based business you
know what i mean like you know
say what you want this is about also
image
you know and you know he's just a big
big guy
you know what i mean he's not
necessarily you know anyway i don't
let me let me not keep going on this
train of thought it doesn't matter you
you
you know what you know what i'm saying
all right let me not i don't need to
explain myself with that
so but now i feel like willie's got a
real good shot
like if it comes down to willy and chase
and willie doesn't win i'm gonna that's
gonna make me upset
but then in the same way though is it
more about being
american out of looking or is it about
talent and that's what it'll come down
to if it's left between those two
and i think it will be i think it's
going between between chase and willie
and that was on tonight actually
because today is sunday i taped it i we
filmed today sunday we turned it around
fast today is monday
and that you're looking at the podcast
so i don't even know what happened i
don't know what's happening tonight on
american idol so
next week i'll have to recap that um so
anyways that's my american idol talk uh
i love that show so i can't wait to see
who wins
and shout out to casey bishop you're
going to be a star
and all these people actually that are
left are really fantastic singers and
performers
chase too let me not be get down on that
dude
he's got it with that you know that
growl like grizzly voice that you like
when white boys play guitar you got that
good white boy voice
and i have a playlist called white boy
music on my spotify i should share with
you guys my spotify playlist
i have i have a lot of i'm very eclectic
music taste i can't listen to
the same type of music all the time like
i can't listen to hip-hop all day
some people can't i can't do it if i
start if i listen to hip-hop all day my
brain
i just i get a headache i just can't
deal with it
the only thing i can listen to all day
is like easy listening alternative rock
that's like you know like you know it's
just you know no no no way
you know that kind of [ __ ] that it's
just on all day you know the early 2000s
in today
i can listen to that like the pulse on
um xm radio i can listen to that station
all day
you know but i also like classical music
so i listen to like i have a i have a
playlist on my spotify called chopin the
man
i can listen to chopin for a few hours
but after a few hours
i'm done with the piano it's like oh man
this is too much for my ears
yeah classical gets like yes right you
know what i mean
it becomes a lot yeah it's nice for a
little while though exactly same thing i
feel like with jazz sometimes
jazz i can listen to jazz and it just
gets to be like okay this is just two
two like yeah yeah
so i got a jab but i listen to jazz i
like country music too
but i can't listen to country music all
day because it just becomes too whiny
you know it's like oh man another sad
story so so i'm very eclectic taste i
like a lot of different types of music
so
anyways um chase is one of those guys i
feel like he's going to make it to
he you know so i don't want to denigrate
the guy i just feel like willie is the
best singer
left and that's saying a lot because
that chick grace is a really great
singer so
shout out to everybody that's left in
america good for you guys all right so
what's going on this week is i want to
talk my nba playoffs preview
now the playoffs have already started as
of this like there's games going on
right now as i'm filming this
episode but it's still it doesn't matter
it's only game one of the playoffs so i
want to do my playoff preview
so nba playoffs preview riffing with
playoffs or whatever you want to say
a lot of great matchups you know if i
had to say though
in the east you i think it's philly i
think it's
the bucks and obviously the nets those
are the three guys i think that have the
best shot of coming out of the east
now okay and then in the west i think
it's still the lakers
even though they lost today lakers lost
but i still think it's the lakers
i think um the clippers who lost
and i don't even know i just think those
two
teams are the two teams i think but
actually at this point right now
who knows so let's look at the brackets
right now so i got the brackets out of
you
looking at youtube and so utah got the
number one seat
i didn't watch utah a lot today a lot
this year
but what i do know of them is they're
probably the deepest team in the league
they're they're well coached uh they are
ready to go
uh you know last year they choked in the
playoffs um they didn't choke but it was
just a fantastic matchup between utah
and denver
but they choked away a 3-1 lead donovan
mitchell is the man he's coming back
he's ready to play
and they have a really like a a
well-rounded team they don't they're not
star-driven they're not a team and you
go ooh that guy donald mitchell is that
guy
and he hasn't proven it yet that you
know he's like a
all like a mvp candidate superstar type
guy
but he's got the talent for that so
utah you know that so so let me see the
brackets again
so you got utah playing memphis who
you know they beat up golden state to
get into the uh
you know the in the in the what what the
playing tournament so they're playing
against memphis and that
is a really you know memphis is an
up-and-coming team but i i don't
i think utah is going to get past them
so this side of the bracket then you got
the clippers
in dallas now my clippers you know i
love the clippers that's my team
i had season tickets before and i love
watching them and supporting them but
you know it becomes a thing where
it's like you know supporting the
clippers is
man it's it it just it see it feels like
you're glutton for punishment to support
the clippers man you know it's like they
have never been to a conference final
and every time they get you
excited like this is gonna be it you
know
it's so funny i you know wiggy just
drank something and his mic is so hot i
heard the
you know what i mean i heard the gulp go
down your throat
no no you don't have to turn it down i
just thought that was funny so you got
the clippers so anyway i've been
supporting the clippers for a very long
time a very long time
and every time i think they're going to
do it they disappoint man they just
disappoint and so now i'm starting to
have now i don't have as much faith as i
had before
because when they had chris paul uh
blake griffin deandre jordan that team
and j.j redick and
you know doc rivers as the coach that's
the year i thought man we could do this
i remember being up 20 on golden state
and i was like and they were undefeated
at the time
golden state was undefeated at the time
we were up 20 in that game
and and they came back and and long we
came back and lost
and i remember somebody from the golden
state press
took a picture of me like we it was like
a tie ball game or something
and steph curry shoots a three-pointer
and a dagger and
it was like a dagger three and they
caught me going like this
like the home alone so that and it was
like on the news the next day
this is what clippers fan so it became
like a meme so i had a little i had like
a very
very low-key meme moment maybe you could
find that way
so the um um so the clippers so right
now
if you look at that bracket the clippers
have a really
like they seem to be the best team in
that
area right and but i don't know they
already lost game one
and alex dallas looks great but i just
don't see dallas being a team that can
win the championship so
i think the clippers are tailor-made
they're ready they got a deep squad but
they got to get it together so
you got that and then let me see it
again the other um
the the other uh teams we got okay so
you got the denver portland matchup and
portland's up 1-0 and i think they
should be up
they're the sixth seed but denver
the fact that they finished with the
third seed is a testament to uh
what's the big center's name um
why am i forgetting to do the dudes uh
the foreign guy from denver
i don't forgot to damn the dude's name
but you guys are probably saying it in
the chat so it doesn't matter you know
who i'm talking about that guy was an
mvp candidate he probably is going to
win mvp and he probably should because
he's he just
he kept that team in it because their
main guy um
what their main guy got hurt you know
what i mean look i got it now i gotta
look up there
now i gotta i gotta look it up because i
feel like i'm just old
denver nuggets
denver nuggets um what what is the
dude's name
wait denver nuggets players here we go
all right so
yeah nico joked the joker djokovic
yeah yeah i got i got it so joke of it
yeah so he and jamal murray is the one
that got hurt
last year jamal murray and donovan
mitchell they were battling in the first
round it was like a fantastic like
this guy scored 50. the other guy scored
40 then it was like it was that kind of
match-up
so he's been hurt he tore his acl so he
hasn't been in the game
you know for the last few months so the
fact that the joker
has got them to the third seat in the
western conference is a testament to
how great he is but in the playoffs i
just don't think that
in the playoffs i don't think that they
uh that um
is he's good enough you know i don't
think i don't think the
denver team is good enough and i think
portland should win that series
and my problem with portland that now is
portland
listen basketball is a tall man's game
okay it just
is it's a big man's game all right
um the portland's
portland's freaking players you know
they're just too
small when it comes to it you know
damien lillard
is a fantastic player mvb mvp
candidate all right he's an mvp
candidate but
he just don't have enough you know what
i mean so you got cj mccullum he's a
small guard
and jamie litter when those are your two
best players
they just they have to do extra no
matter how good they are when they play
against some of these other teams they
got
six seven six eight six nine guys
playing the wings
so i like portland i think they're a
good story
i like to have carmelo anthony's having
a resurgence in his like the end of his
career when people said he was done
now carmelo anthony's still playing but
i don't think portland has enough to win
the championship i just think when it
comes to push comes to shove
and you you're in a playoff series where
the game slows down
and it becomes a half court game they
just they they just don't
have it they don't have enough so
that's that series okay and then when
you look you know
uh going back to the brackets and then
you have like okay so then you have
phoenix and la now phoenix the number
two seed in la now phoenix beat la in
the first
first game but if you look back at
lebron james's career
he loses game one a lot and i think that
that's his move
they lose game one they try to figure it
out and then they come back and win the
series
i think that he's not 100 i don't think
any anthony davis is 100
but i still think they have enough to
beat phoenix now phoenix is a great
story
the fact that they had finished second
in the west
and then they were 8-0 in the bubble
last year coming into this season with
that eight no they got the best record
of any team
they really had a fantastic season chris
paul who should also be an mvp candidate
is ballin and he's got them in the
position where they are right now
so they are 1-0 you know they beat the
lakers in
their first game but i still think the
lakers and then when you look at this
bracket
i think if the lakers can get past
phoenix they got a road to the western
conference championship
that is like the taylormade that is a
perfect road to the finals
but if say the lakers don't win i i'd
love to see phoenix portland
then if that happens if it's phoenix
first portland in the second round
i give portland a shot i think they got
enough to beat phoenix
and then they're in the western
conference final then they're going to
be playing against whatever team that is
it's either going to be
the clippers or you know one of those
teams all right so the western
conference it looks good but it's not as
like
this fantastic western conference that
we've seen in the past so
i think we want the lakers i would love
to see lakers versus clippers in the
western conference final
that's the one we want and right now
it's set up for that
the clippers are deep they're talented
they got kawhi leonard they got paul
george
they got rondo they got demarcus cousins
they got
a little the clippers got a great team
and it would be a disappointment if we
don't see them in the western conference
finals
versus the lakers that's who we want to
see all right we want to see him versus
lakers you know
sergio baca played well the other day
they they really have a great team man
they're like the clippers are deep
they're well coached
they just they're just missing that like
magic thing you know i i can't explain
it but they're missing that stuff
and i hope they find it in this playoffs
so
anyways that's the excuse me that's the
western conference
now let's go over to the eastern
conference
all right so these matchups so the first
one is like
a philly beat washington and this should
be a sweep like
the philly should sweep washington they
the same
situation washington and and portland
got the same issues washington and
portland have the same
issues man it's little ass teams
okay um russell westbrook is a fantastic
player an
all-time great he's gonna go in the hall
of fame he averaged a triple-double for
four seasons and he has the most
triple-doubles in nba history
he is a fantastic player but he himself
alone
is not enough to make a team a champion
he needs like side kicks and
unfortunately his sidekick is somebody
who plays very similarly you know uh
beale
bradley beal who is a dynamic scorer but
he should be paired up with somebody
like lebron james or some other kevin
durant or somebody that's like
or or a power forward like jokic or
somebody that's like a
you know that kind of guy and he he
would be the two you know the one-two
combination the robin to somebody's
you know batman so we got two robins on
this team right now
they just don't have enough but the fact
that they made it into the playoffs they
have a losing record
they won the play-in game tournament
thing and they got in but they're going
to get demolished by philly
philly's just got the philly to me
it should now what we want to see is
philly nets in the west
in the eastern conference finals so you
got that first match up which is
philly versus washington and then you
have the little fun feel-good story
which is uh
nyx atlanta you know i'm not going gonna
talk too much about this but like the
knicks
it's a great story you know they got the
the coach
you know he he coached what's his name
um
thibodeaux you know he coached derrick
rose when derrick rose was mvp
so he's got him on a team he's resurging
in his career
he's got a little renaissance of his
career too you know
julius randle's playing like an mvp so
that looks great
you know what i mean and so we'll see
what's going on with
um you know these playoffs and and
but the knicks like they don't have a
shot to win the championship but it's a
fun story it's great when a team
from new york is actually doing well
it's great for the league it's exciting
east coast west coast it's good to have
those kinds of teams and then you got
the hawks
okay and then the hawks are another
great story their coach i think it's
what's his name
something uh mcmillan or forgot the code
but
he he's doing a great yeah nate mcmillan
he's doing a great job he used to be a
really great player by the way
but you know so they got trae young
you know and trey young's like that
that's their star and they have a nice
little team
clint capela you know these guys that
they have on the team
gallinari they're all like nice
almost all stars sometimes all-star you
know
they're the kind of all-star when like a
main all-star gets hurt
and they're the alternate and they
deserve to be there but they weren't
better than the other great players in
the league
that's this whole team you know so
atlanta is a great story but i think
philly
should get it would be a disappointment
if philly don't get to the west the
eastern conference final
they're better than washington new york
and atlanta hands down they're better
than those teams
and it would be a disappointment if
philly don't get to the eastern
conference final now the lower part of
the bracket
let's go to that wigs lower part of the
bracket there you go
milwaukee miami brooklyn boston okay so
let me start with brooklyn in boston
boston is a they're a disappointment
they won the play in tournament they
shouldn't even been in the playing
tournament they've been in the west
eastern conference final three out of
the last four years i believe
um they're a great team you know uh
boston but boston they don't have enough
i think jalen brown is still hurt
you know but it's um yeah i believe
jaylen brown is still hurt so he didn't
play
and this guy uh jason tatum though is a
star
jason tatum is like the future and you
got kimball walker
who's like a poor man's kyrie irving
they got a good team
they got a good team they're under
achieving they've been under achieving
they should have beat lebron that one
year and they didn't they would have
gone to the championship
they might have won it or they would
have been a they would have lost to
going to state too
but you know that was their chance to
get to the championship a young hot team
like that so
they're still young they're still hungry
i don't know if brad stevens the coach
is
is
getting to them anymore i don't think
he's motivating them enough i think
they're just sick of his voice maybe so
you got that so that series and of
course i've talked about the nets
they should win this series what more
can you say about the nets they finally
got
all three of their stars playing james
harden kevin durant kyrie irving
and they looked fantastic together but
their defense still sucks
so i think they're gonna get their
groove and we're gonna see the nets like
really take off in the playoffs and by
the time it's time for
eastern conference finals and going into
the finals because they should make the
finals they really should but i
still think philly has a shot all right
so that's a
though that's going to be a great
matchup because i don't think anybody on
i think embiid is the most dominant
force on the court
with whoever he's playing whatever teams
playing
he's the most dominant force so
hopefully he rises to the occasion
now we got milwaukee miami they had this
great
overtime game i don't think it should
have been an overtime game
i really feel like milwaukee should have
handled that you know but
you know they lost last year 4-1 against
uh
this mime this upstart miami team i
think miami is that type of team they're
well
coached they're they have a great
organization um
but you know so you're talking about
jimmy butler who is like
like he's just a like a blue collar type
nba player who always gives his all he
works hard
he wants to win he's got the heart of a
champion okay they got to the
championship last year in the bubble
they just weren't going to beat lebron
james and anthony davis you know they
don't have enough on that team
but they got a really you know a smart
solid team with spoelstra
and pat riley running that organization
so they got victor oladipo
tyler hero who's uh he that kid is the
future of the league too
they got a nice team you know like i'm
not surprised when you look at the
roster
miami their roster it holds up against
you know a lot of these other teams in
the league it's just do they have enough
they got to get on the right run they
got to get on the right spark
and we'll see what happens maybe this is
going to be the year
that maybe they do it again but i just
don't see it you know so
in milwaukee now let's go to milwaukee
now milwaukee has been a disappointment
now for three years
uh anta takupo if i'm saying his name
right he's
he's two out of the last three years he
was the mvp he could still be mvp this
year he's got those great numbers but
they're just not going to do that
because they don't give somebody mbp
three years in a row unless it was like
hands down this guy's you know best
record in the league whatever it is like
that but
it's time for him he's got to take care
of business this year he can't be
shut down in the playoffs again like
he's been shut down for the last three
years they just shut him down in the
playoffs
so now it's put up or shut up so
that little mini eastern conference
final in the second round
like what a second round matchup that's
going to be
brooklyn milwaukee that is just
if they make it i think if miami should
get past milwaukee i think boston i
think that the nets
are going to demolish miami but i feel
like nets versus milwaukee
can they do it they got enough
milwaukee's got enough man they got
enough and alexander cooper's got to
play like an mvp
you know so then you're talking about so
that's that so then you're talking about
what we really want to see
i mean i think we would love to see
lakers versus brooklyn in the finals
that would be a great final but i also
think the sixers versus the clippers
would be a great final that's like doc
rivers
that that storyline would be like doc
rivers versus his old team for
in his new team and let's see like you
know what what could happen
you know what i mean like it would be
great for the clippers to beat doc
rivers like
you should have been here you weren't
now we're beating you again so
we'll see what happens man uh it's uh
it's it's it's a really exciting
this is a really exciting playoff year
uh
you know if you're into the nba this is
the time to watch it if you're somebody
that's like always clown in the nba you
think it's fake or whatever it is like
that so what
if you think it's wrestling this is a
great this is this is the wrestlemania
right now so come make sure you
check it out so anyways guys that's my
nba
preview wiki do you like uh nba
basketball do you watch the nba
um i i don't really watch it because we
don't have tv live tv but
i love what like any sports i'll like
always watch it any any type of thing
but my dad uh and how broke people are
i grew up uh like with like at the very
end of the sonics in seattle
oh so like my dad actually took me to a
couple sonic games when i was really
young so that was
i always remember that though all right
well there you go it was a little sweet
moment
yeah my dad actually he did an art piece
in
key arena where the sonics used to play
oh wow that's pretty cool yeah oh look
at you
and shout out to wig's mom yeah shout
out mom she her
his mom watches the podcast yeah yeah so
uh
jiggy we call her because she's julie
yeah wiggy's mom jiggy
she's gonna love this so yeah so
nba it is what it is all right let's get
into um
what i wanted to the movie movie reviews
and tv show reviews so
people have asked me about this numerous
times actually they said have you
watched invincible
on amazon um it's not the invincibles
that's invincible
on amazon and i have i watched it and it
is actually a really great
uh show it's this sort of superhero show
cartoon on amazon
and it's got this really adult story
it's not for kids
i don't think it's for kids i think i
mean i guess i think it's for mature
audiences
you know the mature kids 14 and up or i
don't know i don't know what the rating
on this show is but
it definitely is an adult story so it's
about this uh
but it's kind of a knockoff ripoff of dc
man it's it's so crazy to me
like the the character names and
everything so you know it's about this
guy omni man he's from another planet
like superman
and he's here on earth and there's like
a
there's like a justice league the what
they call the
the globe guardians of the globe which
is like the justice league
you know and here's some of the
characters and you know and it's got
like
i'm telling you this is an all-star cast
of voicing this cartoon like you look at
somebody's names
man seth rogen um
who else go up let's see seth rogen
jk simmons jk simmons um
mark hamill stephen yen from um
walking dead um amber
no what's her name zaria betts uh sandra
oh
does he beat yeah they got uh
who that guy the what's the dude the gay
dude and walter
walton goggins walter i mean the cabinet
this is a freaking
all-star cast it's so it's like amazing
mark hamill is like he's always amazing
voice over actor
um but anyway they got these characters
that are very similar
to the dc so it feels like a knockoff
you know justice league guardians of the
globe
so then they got green ghost which is
like
you know green lantern war woman so
that's
wonder woman you know they got uh what's
that what's the batman guy
they got uh dirk quinn dark wing and
he's like batman
you know they got all you know they got
one guys red rush which is like flash
so it took me like a few episodes to get
past that
because because like for the first few
episodes i'm like what a knockoff this
is
but then you really get engrossed in the
story it's actually a really good story
about like
you know the origins of where omniman
came from and like
you know like this like planetary system
of like there's like you know
people that are overlooking the planets
and then you i don't want to give away
what happens in the end but uh it's like
a really
it's actually a really good story it's
well voiced
like if you if you just look at like if
you you know
like wiggy scroll up and down again one
more time so people can start from the
top so people can see all the different
actors
while i'm talking about this so they can
see all the different people that are in
this cast man
like it's a really like great voice over
actors so
you know you could tell they really put
themselves into it and the story's great
you know
uh it's you know superhero story it's a
father-son story too because this kid
who play he's in he's invincible he
hasn't got his powers yet
he's in high school and then you know
his powers come in
and then now he wants to like you know
follow in his father's footsteps and
he he comes up with his name well i'm
invincible and he like you know he's
trying to be a crime fighter and then
they got all these great characters like
go back go back up again they got this
guy this demon hunter guy i love that
guy
damien dark blood and the guy that plays
him he's a great actor too clancy brown
he um you know you know there's like
there's like
this murder that happens and they you
know that guy's there trying to solve
the murder
zachary kento he plays robot which is
like cyborg
you know um it's just a really
it's a really fantastic cast so you know
invincible is coming to terms with its
powers and you know it's like that whole
father-son dynamic because omni man is
like the you know the heart
hard father who does doesn't show his
emotions and
you know and there's a really
interesting turn that happens in nasa
you gotta check that and then seth rogen
plays this guy
alan the alien who's like a part of like
an interstellar organization that
you know comes to earth but yeah maybe
maybe that's a spoiler alert right there
because you know but it just doesn't
give too much of the story away
you know then you got war woman and then
you know and it's one of these like sort
of like
they make these really interesting like
sort of woke choices and i don't mean it
in a bad way when i say that
because like you know the kid that plays
invincible his best friend
is a gay kid in high school and
invincible is also dating a black girl
you know what i mean
and this is in the cartoon that girl
right there he he's playing you know
he uh played by amber bennett
uh zarya betts no i mean zazia betts or
wait she plays amber bennett
and she's dating the invincible whatever
his name is when he's not invincible
um i forgot the kid's name grayson or
something whatever
grayson yeah mark grayson mark grayson
so mark's just like you know
all-american sort of white boy and you
know and he's dating this black girl and
they don't even
they don't even talk about it you know
and that's one thing i appreciate about
it they just they don't like
there's no reference to race they don't
they don't they just make it they really
normalize it like i'm the one making a
big deal about it
if you if you think about it it's what
me talking about it is what's making it
a big deal you know so i probably
shouldn't so
hopefully one day it won't matter we
won't even think about it but we're not
at that day yet so i'm on a podcast and
i'm talking about it but
i i did find that interesting that they
did that so like again
he's the white guy he's dating a black
girl his best friend is gay
you know and then like and you know it's
it's it's
uh it's an interesting story
you know so they got this and i think i
also i think
i think that the mom played by sandra oh
i also think her character is asian
you know i think that's another thing
too so he's half
quote-unquote white because again his
father's from another planet
and this other planet you know they're
white on this other planet
man's wideness independent but i think
the mom is asian so even if you look at
this character
you know they drew him i believe he's
asian half asian
you know and it's so weird when you're
drawing that you don't want to be too
like stereotypical asiany i guess if
that's such a thing
you know it's like and it's all about
the eyes and how it looks and whatever
the features are that makes someone
asian you know we have this like
terrible stereotype of what we think
that is
but the wife you know played by sandra
oh
if i if i remember correctly just from
watching the show and how the
how the characters are drawn i believe
that so that's what you're talking so
you got a half white half asian kid
dating a black girl who's got a gay best
friend and he's a superhero
and you know he's got father-son issues
and so again
i hope i'm even giving it justice for
you to want to watch it but
it actually is a great show other than
being a dc knockoff
and i feel like they did that on purpose
i feel like the creators of this aren't
stupid
they knew what they were doing so i
guess there was a purpose for that and
maybe i'm gonna do some research maybe
if you guys know too people that are
bigger fans of the show and you're like
really into it and
you know so there's some article you
have where they like oh they did this on
purpose and whatever
uh if you want to find that you know uh
let me know
um but it's a really um
again i think it's a super interesting
show and i'm glad people recommended it
because i
i thoroughly enjoyed it you know and
then they got this new
so these younger subaru here so
something happens to excuse me the main
heroes of the guardians of the globe
so this is like the teen titans again
that come
so these are like the teen titans that
are here
and they're there to like you know
freaking um
take over for the guardians of the globe
because something happens and i won't
tell you what happens but you gotta
check that out
but it's a really again it's a really
good interesting story
you know so make sure you guys check out
invincibles and you haven't watched it
yet huh wigs are going to watch it no
i'm going to watch it yeah it looks sick
yeah cause you watched this next one
that i told you to watch
and this is the other one i want to
review and it's called love
death and robots and it's on netflix
and i gotta tell you guys this is such a
fascinating show for so many
reasons love death and robots on netflix
it is just this it's it's so
it's like this technological advancement
they're showing like it's all this sort
of computer generated
a lot of it is computer generated um
graphics and it looks great like
sometimes when you're watching
i'm not sure you know i'm like and it's
all like
10 to 15 minute stories standalone
stories
you know it's kind of like reminds me of
like um the twilight zone
you know it's very much like that it's
like a twilight zone
of uh these little short stories and
they're all related to like
robots futuristic stuff
they all have that sort of undertone
it's all it's all love stories or it's
about death and they and they involve
robots
right is that a great pretty much yeah
good example of what it is
and it is just really a it's a great
story and like
you don't have to like every single
story by the way like
i'm trying to think of some of the ones
that were my favorite
um i love the one where like
it was like a guy's narrating a story
and like so
a giant a giant man just
shows up that one was great dead on the
beach so like like a how
a whale is on the beach it's just a big
giant
naked man oh by the way a lot of nudity
in this it is awesome let me say this it
is adult
it is an adult cartoon they love to
sneak in nudity whenever they can yes
it's like some really interesting uh
it's a lot of nudity a lot of dick in
this too a lot of cartoons yeah
so if you if you want to be jarred by
some cartoon dick there's a lot of
cartoon dick in this
um so this big giant man
he just shows up on the beach and it's
called man and he's dead all right
and and so it's being narrated by a guy
who is like the um he's like a science
team or something and he's just telling
the story of like
when they found it and how people were
like putting graffiti on it and people
were cutting it up and you know
like some guy it was it just was like a
just an interesting story
and wigs let me ask you did you know
when you're watching it didn't you have
there was moments where you were like it
was like
the way it ended it was kind of like
like anticlimactic endings or
you know it just it just sort of like it
just sort of like
ends yeah it it it left you wishing that
yeah you weren't i mean it left you
wanting more you know yes so many things
and it was like oh you're just going to
leave me
hanging like this but it's cool because
they're they're really digestible
they're short
you know they're like no longer than 25
minutes
no i don't think any of them were long i
think they were all like 10 to 15
minutes i think there was
there was one that i maybe it was from
season i watched them all like yeah me
too
i watched there's there's two seats they
caught them season they call them
volumes
yeah so there's like one that was like
28 minutes but yeah other than that
they're all under
like most of them are no longer than
like 12 minutes you know yeah so
very funny some of them are really funny
yeah they're all funny they're all
cool well i don't think they're all
funny i think that there's a funny one
most of them have like at least some
sense of humor in them a little bit i
don't know i think something except
yeah a couple of them were definitely
pretty dark but there was one
one of the ones i really liked a lot was
like it's some sort of science team
they're out on some like expedition and
they get blasted into space you know
they get blasted into space someplace
and the guy wakes up
and like it's a woman that the heat from
his past is there
and he's like how did we get here and
then it's like really sexy too
they drew her like she was super sexy
and they and then they have like this
really hot
sex but then it turned like i won't give
away
what it is but it's not what it seems
and what what what it was when you found
out
it was like i was just like whoa where
the [ __ ]
i didn't think it was gonna go there
yeah and the ending the way it leaves
you
you're like oh so he's just like you
almost want to like
my friend was he was like oh i think
it's like
heaven and hell and symbolism and this
and that so it's like everybody can take
something different oh that's true
you know i didn't even take it like that
yeah i didn't i didn't either but uh
yeah that's that's something it's like
he's like reliving this loop
of yeah everything but but i think it's
being controlled by but anyways
we don't want to give too much away of
that but yeah it's cool it's like i
would say
it's like if twilight zone and like
black mirror
like had a weird 2021 baby that was
animated you don't want it shorter and
easier to digest
like i i it's like they just said it on
its head like
yeah they're great though very much that
that is a good
way to say that it was there's
definitely some black mirror-ish
elements in there but
it's like anything futuristic nowadays i
feel like any type of that
genre people say yeah people say yeah
exactly
yeah so i i would say um again to
continue with it
is yeah it's and the and the other thing
about it
is this like really fantastic
cgi yeah this computer generated
like but realistic animation
so realistic so because there was
sometimes an episode would start
and i would be like because there was
one episode
oh one of the episodes that was like
really good too is the one with uh
toe for grace yeah yeah oh that one that
one was one of my favorites yeah the one
with toe for grace and it's basically
like
in his refrigerator is like a little
like
little universe like a little community
is like you know like he
he pulls out an ice cube and it's got a
willy mammoth in it you know
and he's like what the hell is this and
he looks inside the refrigerator and he
says oh my god there's like a
prehistoric world going on in his
freezer
and and him and his girl they just kind
of like oh that's cool
you know and every time they close the
refrigerator and open it back up like
a century has passed you know and it
just keeps going technology technology
until like you know this crazy thing
happened but
it's a weird artsy story but that one
was like live action there it is right
there
this one was live action you know and so
you know but again i wonder is it live
action yeah it is it is
that was one of those but on other ones
you're you're like
is it live action and dude they must
have been like i told you i was on
mushrooms too so i was like
is this real or not like wigs was on
mushrooms guys and that's so your mom's
listening so julie
you know she knows uh but yeah i don't
know what you would do
in his childhood that he has to resort
to mushrooms
no these ones were great though so the
um
what am i saying um yeah so sometimes
the the episode would start
and you're like you're like i don't know
if this is a cartoon or not
and then the next thing you know you're
like oh [ __ ] this is a cartoon
now there's something about that live
action animation
that is real it's it's something weird
about it like
it's as close to it looking real as it
possibly can
but there's still something that they
haven't quite fixed it where
they're gonna get rid of actors you know
i think they definitely they've got to
use
real actors in there right like i don't
you know actually i don't know how that
works
for some of those though like wearing
the suit right and then they base it off
who knows man i think they probably they
probably have some program that they put
the stuff on a person yeah and then they
you know they
they they you know they don't you know
how they do that like you ever
see at the mall where you stand in a
thing and they do a 360 uh
thing and then you could get a little
doll of yourself yeah yeah
i think they use that technology to
computerize the person and then they can
do whatever they want inside the
computer because i would notice like
when they did that when they did animals
it's like the animal movements didn't
look quite
exactly how animals would but the people
movements were pretty like
yeah but it's still it's there's still a
little chocolates too it's still like
yeah a little bit like video game yes
it's very
video it's very like the stupid stories
in between video games yeah it's like
the
it's like the story mode of video games
yes the dumb which i can't stand by the
way which i can talk about in another
episode it's like
yo man i just want to shoot [ __ ] let me
let me go on a quick tangent so i got
the avengers game
and i love it because i love playing
that's the hulk because it used to be
this game
called the it was like the hulk
incredible hulk game and it was just you
would just smash [ __ ] and i loved it
i just want to smash [ __ ] i get a video
game i want to shoot things smash [ __ ]
that's what i want to do
i don't need this woke-ass uh storyline
where you have to play as this girl
who's like you know going on her quest
with the avengers and it's like i i want
to skip past it every time i can't stand
that stuff that's just me
i don't care about your dumb story when
did we get the gun in my hand and i can
just like kill aliens because that's all
i want to do all right
so please keep your story you should
always have the option to skip the story
okay that's just my opinion all right
wait i gotta take a shower to blow my
nose i always have this sinus thing man
and people say something about it too
all the time like yo man drink some
water or you're making noises
i feel like an old ass man you don't
hear till like i'm listening to the edit
and i'm like damn i sound like old ass
man but
hey guys it is what it is you know what
i mean this is free content
you know what you want me to do you know
you want to
go go watch netflix you know but love
robots death love death and robots
uh i do i highly recommend this
show and if you're you know you smoke
weed you take mushrooms
it's a great show for that you know it
is i can see that when you said that to
me
yeah wig skills i was on mushrooms my
first thought was like oh
yeah this is a perfect show for this so
if you're watching on youtube right now
look at this animation man
we're just showing the trailer for it
right now i mean there's like great
detail in the eyes and look at that this
doesn't even do it just
it really doesn't but like even that
right there you watch it on netflix
you'll see
yeah if you're watching on a good tv
you're just like oh and and some of the
animation was like
very stylistic yeah like this episode
was yes insane yes
that was a really sick episode yeah
exactly so it's like
this one was great that was one of my
favorites too
that one's like a real a take on
christmas yeah you know and it's one of
those things where you go
you know okay i know i got it i got it
what they did
with a lot of these stories is they left
it open to your
interpretation and your imagination to
see where it goes
or where it came from and i really
enjoyed that
but that one right there this episode
we're looking at right there about is
two little kids and it's a christmas
episode
yeah my friend was like like oh i want
to see what happens
like when you're bad at like at the end
of this one
don't don't don't get don't don't give
it away right no spoiler alerts on this
because i do want people to watch it
because they are
short digestible yeah they're like you
could watch the whole new season in
under an hour yeah it's a great watch
it's a great it is a great watch so
kudos to um oh that one was
you see were you talking about humor
like this episode right there
that one right there that was the
futuristic old people uh
the one dude that one was dark as hell
yeah
that's a dark ass episode like don't
think these are all it's not it's
that's why i disagree with you it wasn't
all fun and games no they're not all
fine again no some of these are really
dark are you talking about the with the
kids
no the vacuum one was funny no i'm
talking about the one where
they they've they've cracked immortality
oh yeah that one is dark it's illegal to
have
it's illegal to have kids that one was
super dark you know what i mean yeah
it was dark as hell man and this one's
funny this one where the vacuum cleaner
kind of goes crazy and she's on uh
she's on the customer service line like
it's a lot a lot of them are funny and
they're just
but they're dark because even that [ __ ]
is dark you know
so it's like i again i i wanna i said it
a million times but
watch that episode watch that series
love death
robots it's on netflix and i highly
recommend it
and make sure you check out invincibles
2 on amazon prime if you have amazon
prime it's
it's worth it like the the dc knockoff
stuff it doesn't matter
it's still a great watch and it's it's
and it has some fantastic actors in it
like
the voice the voice the accumulation of
talent in that
show is off the chains off the charts so
check that out okay
so i talked about american auto nba and
i did my movie reviews that i wanted to
do
so now it's time that time in the show
where we go over to
wigs has got some stuff for me so
wiggy's corner oh no we can't have
wiggy's corner because that's like
rachel's corner
yeah wiki's world wiki's world yeah
getting wiggy with it yeah yeah we will
figure it out so
what you got for me this week well
we should get some you know what and
this is a moment too where you guys if
you guys have fan mail
if you want to like you know uh uh send
in some stuff or whatever
you know now's the time this is a now i
have somebody for this and you and you
made an email i believe you made that
email yeah i made a
uh riffin advice gmail.com so
you can send all the grown ass man
advice
and um any questions any scenarios yeah
so you don't have that on the screen
it's probably on the screen now look
right there
you can see the email right there guys
and so start or
they up there wherever you want to have
it so make sure you like if you want to
like
that will go directly to him so you
could uh um
you know whatever you have to say about
the show and email and all that kind of
stuff and then we'll start you know
yeah advice yeah anything anything yeah
anything movie reviews movies you want
to
review uh anything all the music
yeah music yeah that's a good two
actually actually but the only thing i
hate
i would hate to review music because
then you know what i can't
i mean it depends how big they are but
yeah well no they they they
the algorithm catches it okay youtube
itself catches it
no matter how big or small it is it
lasts no but i mean how big the artist
is because maybe it won't no no
it's in their system man they have a
copyright whole you know it's like
once it's in the jerk once it's in the
machine it's in the machine no matter
how big or small
because i had a kid give me some music
and it was his own copy written music
and then i got dinged for it so i was
like so when i tell people when you send
me music don't send me something that
you're going to like
try to make money on later because
you're going to mess me up yeah
so you're just sending me music because
you're like i want to send you this and
i'm using it on my
podcast look what happens to my hair
when i do this all right anyways
all right so what you got all right what
do i got i got uh
well let's just we haven't ever really
talked about this i don't know what you
what your uh thought of it is but um
what do you think about dogecoin bitcoin
oh cryptocurrency
um well what is what is this what what
what's going on this is
uh this is my robin hood it's it was
originally like
40 bucks oh so it's still going up
obviously now
well no it was it went up
and then now it's going back down but
you're still up yeah i mean i'm still up
from
forty dollars yeah let me look at mine
i'm actually on robin hood too
i got some dogecoin too because i bought
i bought it at four cents
oh good for you i wish i wish i would
have done that i got lucky
so i don't want a year so like i'm still
up
now now i'm up 2 745
oh nice yeah so i'm up on my dot on that
you know that's good but
when do you buy dogecoin i bought it i
forgot when i bought it but i bought it
it was it was like 14 cents or something
something like that you know and i had
you know it's crazy i had some bitcoin
i had some bitcoin when it was at 6 000
and i sold it
i still made a big profit but i when it
got to 60 i looked i was like
what yeah i don't know i
i i mean i put like my leftover
i got like free stocks and then sold
them and put the remainder into bitcoin
oh but then it crashed dude
i have no idea how it works i don't
understand
it that's kind of what i'm trying to
learn i'm trying to like i just think
that it'd be
get a better idea to me it means nothing
it's just like a service that they've
like to me i'm from old school like i
wanted to be
you make something or you sell something
or you provide
something yeah and you know i don't know
what
bitcoin you know i know actually i
understand like bitcoin's the one
the only one i get in terms of like all
right so if you want to use this to
you know to have an untraceable source
of way to send money and receive money
for particular services okay so this is
like the a new gold system yeah you got
bitcoin
but all the other ones i don't get yeah
i don't really get
i don't i don't really understand it's
like it's like if somebody came up with
their own gold
if somebody came up with their like
somebody said okay so we have the gold
standard and somebody can't well i have
the
the load standard you know and it's like
it's just like gold
you go well why is that valuable so
that's what i feel about like all these
cryptocurrency
blockchain i don't understand it at all
so maybe if you want to explain it in
the comments
because i know because like it's just
like with covid everybody in the
comments somehow is like a scientist
yeah
we need a crypto wizard yeah we need a
crypto guy to like any crypto wizards
want to come on
we'll uh we'll hear what you got to say
explain it to me so
what i have to say about that is like
hey don't use
it's gambling okay what you're doing is
high stakes gambling
so don't use money that you need to pay
bills
to buy dogecoin okay that's what my
advice to you is that
if you have some extra money laying
around like rachel put a hundred dollars
in
but it was too late like you know what i
mean so it just crashed
no no she had her hundred dollars in
there right and then this is rachel
she's looking at her phone and she's
going like this
she's like she's 100 she's like oh my
god 106.
that's like my friend he put in 25 and
he was like he's like oh it's a 31.
oh oh it's at 32. oh we're back down to
31 he was like just watching i'm like
you
can't watch it yeah you can't watch it i
told her too so now she's
now it was up 200 so she had 200
now it's back down to 100 and a little
bit less or like i said a hundred so now
she's like
what happened to my other hundred
dollars yeah yeah see i was almost at
like 900 bucks i should have this
yeah that's what you don't oh well it
shoulda woulda it's 40 bucks you know
you never know it could go on a run
again right exactly it could just
skyrocket back i mean that's at a
certain point you know like if it just
gets to
i just wanted to get to where like
litecoin or ethereum is
like if don't get like it went there
we're on yeah
yeah if we got to uh if we got to 100 i
did the math i was like if it hits a
hundred bucks i make like
a little over a hundred grand if it hits
a thousand bucks that's a million
like yeah i've done all the math so yeah
yeah i just used to 100 i have
i have i have house money now yeah
so i'm just gonna have my doge house i'm
gonna call it
that would be sick yeah my doge house so
yeah but that's really
i know we didn't tell you i know this is
like nothing i didn't give you any
information or anything but
all i'm saying is like i don't know how
it works it just seems fun
it seems like it's going to it's like
it's like it's like having an
app that's like online casino app yeah
that's what robin hood feels like to me
and and i even went to like i got it's
like one of those eight ball pool apps
where you can win
like real money via paypal or something
yeah
yeah yeah so anyways all right that's
our
cryptocurrency crypto yeah this goes
into
kind of into love death robots a little
bit there's
robot we got robot police dogs now oh
what i don't know if
this is i think this is kind of old but
we've been had these probably but yeah
there's some guy getting arrested
and we got
there he is i don't know what he's doing
like you think like is it i've never
seen nothing like this before
in my life like what is it
what is that doing yeah
all right i some black mirror yeah like
like it to me it would be like you could
turn it off
because or turn the volume down to me
it's like like
like i was in a hotel
i was in this like fancy hotel in boston
when i was shooting this movie
sleepover for boston and they have a
robot
that just is roaming around the hotel
you know
they got this robot roaming around the
hotel and
delivering [ __ ] for people so it would
be in the elevator
you kind of just got to kind of you kind
of got to just get out of its way too
it's not like it it's not like it like
stops or or you know it just
i don't know how it works and that's
like the future of it it's the same
thing with um
it's the same thing with like the the
pizzas being delivered
you know yeah like yeah that robot right
there yeah
that's the kind of thing they got so
they got these robots in hotels that are
just like delivering [ __ ] you know so
it's so bizarre
and then they got like so now i don't
know if if that thing is happening or
not or if it's real or not is like pizza
hut delivering
pizza with robot cars now
you know i thought they have the
commercial for that and that just made
me go well hold on a second
so you got if the so pizza can drive
on the road but a person can't be in a
car right now being like
remote controlled or or you know ai
controlled
what do you call self-driving cars so
they got the self-driving
pizza delivery wow this is crazy yeah
right
do you see it on there i mean yeah so
pizza hut's got the
you know this like delivery thing that's
like roaming around the city
i haven't seen one that's black mirror
pretty much right and i think even
amazon
i think even amazon is delivering
packages now
um the packages are roaming around
the city delivering stuff too i thought
it was gonna be like the drone things
flying delivering packages but
i don't know i mean it's just like is
that is that the future right now it's
like you know
those type of jobs are gonna go away i
mean i think that the self-driving cars
eventually i mean because i don't know
how many people
but i'm sure you have numerous friends
in your age bracket who are driving uber
and lyft you know there's people that's
what people do now yeah
there's people who were like they made
that a career doordash
they know what they do at all yeah
you're delivering uber you're i mean
you're delivering ubereats you're
driving uber then you do doordash all
these kinds of things
and that's what you're so once they get
self-driving cars it's a wrap
like you know what's going to be that
type of job
yeah look at that right there there's
the this amazon thing
but to me it's like so like thieves and
homeless people they just like they just
go swoop that out
bash it like is it gonna be yeah they're
just gonna bash it open or is it
what my question is does it have some
kind of defenses on it
that's what i want to know like spikes
pop out yeah like yeah dude like is it
spike is it like does it electrocute
people does it warn you that's gonna be
the future of it too like you have four
seconds to wrong get away or you're
gonna be killed you know
so i mean that's the future of stuff man
where they're just gonna be like
completely delivering delivering stuff
you know i do have like a like a side
story about this that something happened
to me the other night and this is
something i
don't i want to know if anybody's
experienced this too
so i was coming home late from the
comedy store
and i wanted to rachel was hungry and i
wanted to get something to eat too
right and so i look on the app and i
find a restaurant restaurant in my area
that was open
and it was like a certain restaurant so
i went and i so i ordered pick up
because
because i signed up for the grubhub
thing i actually signed up
to be a member because you get 10 off
when you pick it up so once a month
it's cool to like go pick it up you get
that 10 reward and it pays for itself
in that way you know so
i find a restaurant it's called
crispy chicken or whatever it was called
right and then
i went and i got there
and i'm driving around because i can't
find a place i'm looking at the sign
and it's like a it's like a uh pizza hut
it's a pizza place
it's some like new york style pizza
place so i go wait a minute maybe this
is
it's in the back or something so i pull
up and i get out and there's a guy
waiting there and it's like you could
tell it's a lot of like grubhub
postmates type people who are trying to
pick food up
and i said to the guy go yo dude is this
the chicken spot and he's like
oh yeah man this place is like five
different restaurants
on the app
ghost restaurants that's is that what
that was yeah you just
yeah so so this place
this place is not just one restaurant so
when you're driving by
it look like a pizza place okay it says
the sign it says pizza
new york style pizza forgot the name of
the place right
but it's also a chicken place a cookie
place
an italian it had like four or five
different restaurants in this one
location
and everybody i saw i'm talking to the
people i go well where's what is this
and so cause somebody walked up and go
is this the cookie spot and i was like
the cookie spot
yeah apparently they're doing this with
like tons of different uh
places like they're doing it it this
actually this went like viral on the
internet a while ago
uh cause chuck e cheese's was changing
the name
on delivery apps and they would and they
called it they called themselves
pasquale's pizza and
wings because they knew that they'd get
less business as chuck e cheese so they
would
that makes sense that started a whole
thing and actually i have a friend
who uh he runs emo night la it's like a
promotion they throw
shows and stuff it's just sad white kids
yeah more or less but they they throw
like parties
you know like is there parties or is it
just people being saved
no it's it's they're they they're
serious they're uh they're big they they
popped off they got they were
pretty popping for a while you'll have
to before the paper you have to explain
emo to me another episode because i
don't know but
um they they started a a side thing
where they start a restaurant and it's
like
in the same location well it's it's the
same sort of thing where they
they get it done with a kitchen it's
it's this they do lots of stuff but um
you look how sad that kid is they go
back to it
he does that this is exactly what i'm
saying it does look like look how
freaking sad this kid looks on emo night
like he looks sad as hell like i wonder
if i'm on here i modeled for them once
um but uh yeah wait emo it's called emo
bite
oh i forgot where it is they it's called
emo bite and they do it on
the delivery apps and it's the same sort
of thing where well first of all
they do a ghost ghost kitchen and it's
like wait wait wait wait
don't catfish me with your food that's
catfish exactly fish food
exactly so this is the new catfish well
i come to a restaurant and i'm like
just say the chicken place but with them
they i mean
with them they just used it as a way to
do that no but
i don't appreciate it if i want to go to
a place that all they do is make chicken
so i know that they're experts at
chickens yeah i don't want to come to a
place where it's like oh you guys make
pizza and you just throwing some chicken
in the stove
making me feel like and you know what by
the way the chicken wasn't good
the chicken was burnt i had to i had to
i went on to the app and i was like my
food was
overcooked the french fries were
overcooked and the chicken was
overcooked
and i was upset about that cause i was
like see cause y'all don't know how to
make chicken cause you make pizza
pick pick up you can't be catfishing me
with the food that's what that is it's
food
it's food fish wait look at this what is
it this says how to start a virtual
restaurant
well there you go on and it's on the
ubereats website yeah well i mean i
could do it i mean launch a virtual
restaurant
i can just i just have people comment i
can just make like you know i can just
boil eggs
i can make peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and you just get them
griffin's egg shack
yeah but you don't have to have hey you
don't have to have like a license
and and like you know you've got you got
it you're right you can't just like be
giving people food
right well these these i don't like
these catfish restaurants man
these catfish restaurants got to go yeah
there was another one that was doing it
too not just chuck e cheese i forget
what yeah
yeah you you're gonna have to be real
with me okay
if you if you like making italian food
and you're an expert at italian food
don't be making chinese food on the side
yeah you're not a real chinese place you
can't do it all pick one that you're
good at
all right that's that rant what else
we've been going a while
going maybe a couple more okay um on
wiki's world
this is just [ __ ] hilarious um
i don't know if you ever saw this video
but it's pretty fun
so dude just yeah scored a goal yeah
this is what like what
where that's why i don't go to park
games you know what i mean like well
that's gotta be where the [ __ ] is
that that can't be some place yeah that
can't be like that can't be down the
street
you know what i mean like
damn dude what if like somebody like
just
in the in and they why and why does it
gotta be
like an automatic pistol too i know just
like that's just part of the problem
right there
like so casual with it too like good job
kid
[Music]
man like that that's that's just scary
so yeah so
for people listening so you know it's
like a outdoor
real look like a shady park and somebody
kicks a goal
and the you know it looks you know what
it looks like it looks like
it looks like it was a challenge you
know what i mean it looks like like
like like well it looks like it went
into like extra
extra goals no no no no no no just look
like now let me finish it looks like
this is a gang okay and two dudes was
talking smack
and the dude was like you can't score a
goal on me that's true you know what i
mean another dude was like scoring you
right now fool and they were like let's
go to the park and do it
so then they like oh they have the
barbecue already there and they just
this department
has got a big old watch on yeah and then
there's like a you know a goal right
there so the one dude's like all right
try to score on me
then the dude scores on him and then the
other guy's like oh
and he pulls out his semi-automatic
pistol and
he blows it up in the sky like dude yeah
that is so that's probably that's the
that's the story of that which is like
yeah that's probably what i wouldn't
want to be like at the park with my kids
and you just like oh look what's
happening over there
a dude just you know because those
bullets have to come down
where are those bullets yeah i mean
that's incense right i don't think
that's a real thing i think that's been
myth busted
do you remember you ever watched
mythbusters they had a one where they
said it kind of
yeah you drop a penny from the empire
state they they were like
they they myth busted yeah they busted
myths yeah or like uh
they did i saw the one where like you
know it's so hot you can cook an egg on
the sidewalk and that was yeah that was
myth busted you can't
no matter how hot it is what were some
good ones they did a ton of good
yeah they had they had a ton of good
ones right there i should do a myth
busting
right i meant i do a myth bust we'll
have to figure that out yeah we should
figure that out but griff bus yeah griff
bust we'll call him griff bus but listen
guys uh i appreciate you guys uh once
again
being here watching listening
subscribing
liking working with griffin um you know
another another episode of bites to dust
another
we did it again so make sure you catch
me i'm usually
gaming daily on eric griffin gaming um
still auditioning for stuff
i remember i talked about an audition i
had last week that didn't they didn't
want me
but now i got a new audition that i'm
gonna have wigs help me with
[Laughter]
so let's see if so if i get that one
then he's gotta be my new audition guy
my old my normal audition guys ben you
guys i've had ben on the podcast bed and
c-word
and he's really great doing that for me
because we would do it virtually because
you know he couldn't you know you
couldn't go anywhere because of covert
and all that stuff so he's been
help and we booked a movie so i booked
that ray romano movie with an audition
that i did with ben so
so that that worked out so we finally
got one um so we'll see if this one
works out um because this is a
this is another another good job it
would be but you know
hey it is what it is like you get those
they come and go
you know a lot of it has to do with like
timing you know so but anyways
[Music]
i'll keep you posted on that continue
watching the playoffs just to recap you
know i uh clippers
i'm pulling for my clippers and i would
love to see like you know clippers nets
would be good too
clippers sixers would be good but you
know lakers nets is also a fantastic
final so we went over that
uh shout out to all the american auto
people and their air condo fans check
that out make sure again you watch
love uh death robots on netflix and
invincible
on amazon prime i just reviewed those so
that was great and you know thanks again
for being here thanks to wigs wigs uh
thanks for coming again and
you know we've gotten more positive
feedback than negative so we'll just
continue going and keep trying to grow
the podcast and see where it goes from
here
and guys thanks for watching richard
griffin appreciate you guys yeah
appreciate you making and what's the and
make sure you you send
stuff to the new email riffing advice i
don't know why you made it that because
sometimes it's not always about advice
but you know
we agree different advice at
gmail.comgmail.com so check that out
and thanks again for watching with
griffin and i will see you
next week
[Music]
you